a Donald Trump's lawyer Christina Bob is
lawyering up and willing to cooperate
with the Department of Justice my how
quickly things change when you are one
of Donald Trump's lawyers remember
Maga really means making attorneys get
attorneys Salon reports Trump attorney
lawyers up and says she's willing to
cooperate with doj and Mar-A-Lago case
at least one member of former president
Trump's legal team has hired her own
lawyer and allies are urging another to
follow suit Trump attorney Christina Bob
and Trump attorney Evan Corcoran
affirmed to the justice department that
Trump did hand over all those classified
records from Mar-A-Lago but prosecutors
say that that wasn't true
the response was incomplete after the
FBI searched and found more documents
Bob who by the way is also an anchor on
right side broadcasting if you can
imagine the incestuous nature of what's
going on there Bob has since hired her
own lawyer and made it known to Trump
allies she is willing to cooperate and
be interviewed by the justice department
colleagues have also urged Corcoran to
hire a criminal defense lawyer because
of his response to the subpoena
according to the report he insists it's
not necessary Bob told the Washington
Post when asked whether she was
negotiating for a sit-down interview
with the doj I'm sorry I'm not allowed
to talk about it now remember Bob's
relevance in this entire thing that is
in this article where it says quote Bob
signed a document affirming that Trump
handed over all the documents that are
responsive to The subpoena after a
diligent search Corcoran then met with
doj officials and made a similar
statement they then found that that was
not actually true
now another important aspect of this is
that Bob
um helped push Trump's legal challenges
after the election and has insisted that
she believes the document she signed was
accurate but she also told right side
broadcasting she's not actually acting
as Trump's attorney while serving as a
custodian of Records she's only doing
the custodian of Records thing so listen
here's the bottom line on this even if
you are a trump supporter how can you
justify him taking the documents what is
your explanation for what he was
planning to do with them and why did he
lie about them having been returned did
he not know and you believe Christina
Bob is the one who lied well Christina
Bob says she signed off on it because
she believed the documents were returned
so who told her because if it's not
Trump who said uh lie and say the
documents were returned and if Christina
Bob was just doing what she was told who
came up with we are going to claim
the documents were returned uh the next
part of it is are any ex of the
explanations that anybody has given
believable right the documents were for
Trump's library that he doesn't care
about the documents were for Trump to
write his Memoirs even though Trump
doesn't write the documents were for
Trump to read even though Trump doesn't
read the documents were uh uh
Declassified telepathically right before
the FBI planted them none of the stories
make sense and what we're learning is
every single one of these people is in
over their heads think about the number
of red flags here and what it sounds
like is that Christina Bob realized
people are going down this is a very
serious criminal investigation the FBI
knows that we didn't really return the
document my name is there saying the
documents were returned and she is now
trying to distance herself but the theme
is being Trump's lawyer really doesn't
go well it often doesn't go well
financially
although Trump's Lewis newest lawyers
are collecting money up front which is
smart of them to do and it often doesn't
go well criminally or in terms of your
legal career either Christina Bob has
lawyered up who will be next find me on
Twitter at D Pacman and let me know one
of our sponsors is paired the app for
couples every day paired gives you and
your partner questions quizzes games to
have fun to stay connected to deepen
your conversations and get to know each
other better what's great about it is
you don't even have to be in the same
room especially with the baby right now
my girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent go to paired.com Pacman to
download the app and get a seven day
free trial the link is down below